[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here and this
is the google nexus 4 and it's finally
here shipping out in waves from the
Google Play Store as the successor to
the Samsung Galaxy Nexus so Google
partnered with LG to make this device
and on the outside it's pretty easy to
see how the LG Nexus 4 came to be the
next Nexus it looks pretty similar on
the front to the last one both have
similar curvatures similar sensor
placement up top and no ugly branding or
any logos elsewhere on the phone both
have little Chin's and they both seem to
embody the Nexus feel in fact the Nexus
4 is an almost perfect hybrid falling
right in between the LG Optimus G and
the Galaxy Nexus and a lot of ways first
of all the Optimus G on the left is that
square shape the Galaxy Nexus on the
right is very curvy so the Nexus 4 here
in the middle is a nice hybrid between
those two looks the Nexus 4 also takes a
glass of the front and back of the
optimus G along with the sealed in
battery the slot speaker and the 8
megapixel camera it also takes its LTE
chip but we'll get to that in a second
from the Galaxy Nexus it takes at pure
Android 4.2 experience the beautiful
pulsating notification light we loved so
much and that very clean Nexus look on
the front something it doesn't take from
either phone though is that backing
behind the glass is this textured almost
glittery pattern that no other phone has
and when it catches the light right it
looks awesome it's very bright very
vivid very very different from other
phones you can't actually feel the
texture when holding the phone but
underneath that glass there's some LG
handiwork that makes it twinkle and
catch a few eyes so overall on the
hardware front the Nexus 4 is definitely
a good premium feeling phone its Gorilla
Glass 2 on the front and on the back but
it has this nice soft touch material on
the beveled sides which makes it really
nice to hold I think Google spent a lot
of time making this phone of pleasing
one-handed experience and I think they
did a good job and it's a little tiny
bit heavier than the Galaxy s3 but it's
definitely a light phone very much
lighter than most other phones out there
oh and don't drop this phone it does
have Gorilla Glass 2 on the back and
everything but if it hits the right
angle it
we'll crack anyway and Google does sell
a bumper and the Google Play Store for
those of you who may drop your phones a
lot but phones aren't meant to be
dropped so don't drop this guy now the
Nexus 4 is an awesome upgrade from the
unlocked Galaxy Nexus the price is super
low and you can just pop your SIM card
out of one and into the other literally
everything about the phone is an upgrade
so from the Snapdragon s4 pro quad-core
processor which is a boss to the two
gigabytes of ram to the new 8 megapixel
camera everything is an upgrade if
you're on the Verizon Galaxy Nexus
though it's a tough choice to end your
contract and move to a new plan but I
can still recommend it for the true
nexus experience you can see comparing
the displays that there is also a huge
improvement here the Nexus 4 has a 1280
by 768 IPS display and it gets way
brighter and it's super easy to read in
broad daylight
unlike the dimmer AMOLED displays on
things like the Galaxy Nexus and this
display makes watching movies and even
HD YouTube videos a great experience but
the speaker kind of hinders that a bit
it's loud but it's super tinny and you
can accidentally cover the whole thing
with your finger and then you just can't
hear it at all but the screen makes a
video watching experience a definite
plus it's not like a terrible speaker or
anything but it's something you should
note and the new 8 megapixel camera on
the Nexus 4 is quite good it actually
surprised me I'd say it's about on par
with the galaxy s3 and the Galaxy Note 2
and the shots you can get out of it
especially with HDR mode on it can look
like they came out of something other
than a cell phone camera so that's great
and 1080p video out of this guy looks
nice too and you can take pictures while
you are recording video just by tapping
the screen while the video is recording
now to focus on the Snapdragon s4 pro
for a second this is a 1.5 gigahertz
quad-core processor running Android 4.2
jelly bean with project butter so by
that logic
everything should be buttery smooth and
snappy and almost everything is but
there are still a few problems with
chrome sometimes and the occasional
dropped frame in certain pinch-to-zoom
animations but real world performance is
still noticeably snappier than any other
Android phone I've ever used this is a
ridiculously
device and what's interesting is that
there are still some apps that are
clearly not optimized for Android 4.2
and you'll be able to tell when you're
looking at them so that'll be up to
developers to fix and that's what leads
me to believe that benchmark scores were
unusually low I mean I got fifty three
hundred or so on quadrant while the
Optimus G with the same processor and
RAM broke seven thousand so yeah
optimization is an ongoing process but
definitely real-world performance
opening apps flying through multitasking
all the typical things that you do every
day on your phone when you're you're
navigating places and you have multiple
applications open at once that's all
going to be very very fast Gaming is
also excellent I can promise that the
Nexus 4 handles games like a boss I'm
not a huge gamer but I've played Need
for Speed on so many other platforms
that I had to get it here and it is
super fun frame rates are high
everything looks great on this display
and it's all just super responsive I
haven't found any games that look bad
yet on the Nexus 4 it does however heat
up a little bit on the back sometimes
and you can replicate this by playing a
game or two for yourself and in just a
few minutes it'll be warm not a big deal
to most people but it's weird to
actually feel the processor working hard
anyway of course the biggest reason
people buy this phone is for pure
Android 4.2 jelly bean and all its
awesome features and fast updates
straight from Google as the stock
Android experience is a buying point by
itself so lucky for you I have an entire
separate video linked in the description
down below the like button on this video
detailing the new features in Android
4.2 and they are all present on this
phone now you would think that with no
LTE and a sealed in 2100 milliamp hour
battery that the Nexus 4 would last
forever on a battery but to be honest it
has just average battery life nothing
spectacular it gets you through the day
don't get me wrong but this is not a
phone that's gonna get you crazy you
know four hours of screen on time or
anything also there was an issue
reported with some Nexus 4 is having
staticky earpieces during calls but I
never had that problem with mine so
that's a good sign and also LTE yeah
it's it's based on the LTE optimus G
I'll give you that so it still has the
LTE chip inside but there's no amplifier
and it
early supports one band and you have to
do some interesting little hackery to
get it unlocked so it's not exactly true
LTE support natively but it's a great
coincidence for some lucky Canadians
though because their carriers do work
with this one band and there are a few
simple steps to unlock this LTE also
apparently t-mobile's LTE will use this
band so we'll see how far the hackers
and modders will take that so overall
what would make someone want to buy this
Nexus 4 well number one if you want
stock Android right out the box and the
fastest updates straight from Google and
support for Android 4.2 jelly bean right
out the box then this is your phone
right here no question if you want a
very inexpensive high bang for your buck
unlocked phone then this is also a great
choice if you won't settle for anything
less than that Snapdragon s4 pro chip
then this is definitely a great choice
- I wouldn't buy this phone specifically
for the camera or for the battery life
but they're certainly acceptable as far
as high-end smartphones go I would even
go to say and this is one of the best
value smart phones out there right now
and it's certainly the best nexus to
date it seems to almost completely
naturally separate itself from the rest
literally so there you go guys that's
the LG Nexus 4 like I've said it's
definitely one of the higher-end
smartphones out there and it competes
with the highest end on the market right
now even at its lower price point in the
Google Play Store and at the link down
below the like button on this video now
there are a couple of things you do need
to know before buying something like the
Nexus 4 while it is definitely a worthy
upgrade from the GSM Galaxy Nexus you
are going to lose a few things because
of the lower budget specifically like we
addressed the lack of LTE so you won't
be able to get this on Verizon and yes
you can technically get LTE on it on one
band on a couple of Canadian carriers
and potentially t-mobile in the future
but that's not a buying point for this
phone right now even if you do get it on
t-mobile it's just a bonus if it happens
to work later but honestly this is a
really great phone and I would have no
problem recommending it to anyone on
AT&T or t-mobile who has a SIM card
that's ready to throw this in an
unlocked phone and get it working other
than that thank you for watching this
video if you have any questions at all
about the
anything I miss anything you would like
to know more about feel free to leave a
comment down below and you can see I'm
answering them as many as I can and
definitely give a thumbs up if you enjoy
the video and subscribe for the upcoming
Nexus 10 review and much much more
content to come so again thank you for
watching and I'll talk to you guys later
[Music]